on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook and uncensored a
predictable Panic on the left as Elon
Musk takes charge of Twitter is this A
Brave New Dawn for free speech as I
believe or open season for hateful
trolls I'll talk live to Caitlyn Jenner
pressure builds on the new Home
Secretary who was the last 10 secretary
over Britain's migrant crisis and a
growing security Scandal over her
private emails is it time to sack leaky
Sue again
plus fears of Prince Harry's sex stuff
his Memoir to inflect maximum damage on
the royal family should he now be
stripped of his remaining Royal titles
live
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored it's Halloween
and something very very scary is
happening I'm not talking about a
ghoulish
it's not even the inflation rate it's
Elon musk's takeover of Twitter and
according to many so-called liberals who
use the site obsessively which will be
very very afraid
it's like the Gates of Hell opened on
this site said this Washington Post
columnist all the red lights are
flashing here says Ben Collins of NBC
this is an emergency Twitter's about to
be taken over by the evil Sith Lord says
this professor most absurdly of all look
at this MSNBC commentator who told his
fellow crybaby stay hold your ground
like a Ukrainian
sorry
a free speech loving Maverick takes over
a social media site and it's the
equivalent of a genocidal dictator
trying to take over a country and wait
who's been helping the ukrainians oh
that would be Elon Musk by donating a
hundred million dollars worth of his
starlings these satellites which help
the Ukrainian military connect with each
other when everything else has been
destroyed
is he really the enemy to the Ukrainian
people
America's top liberal TV network will
also collapsed into an immediate
predictable spasm of panic
official musk is in top executives are
out and the far right is rejoicing what
are we in for yes well there you are
that kind of says it all um you know I
think it's going to be really difficult
when did Free Speech become far right
Elon Musk isn't even conservative
he's a fan of Bernie Sanders that's left
wing as a as a politician gets in
America
well these people are really scared
about is hearing opinions they don't
agree with and having their own opinions
challenged Twitter has for a long time
now been managed by a very woke
Workforce which has systematically
Shadow banned and buried commentators
who are mainly on the right all Elon
Musk has said is he wants to restore
Twitter to what he should have been a
digital Town Square or a wide range of
beliefs can be helpfully debated that's
not opening the gates of hell it's not
death threats in science to violence or
hate speech we have a word for those
things already it's called crime
a Free Speech Twitter simply means open
debate about different ideas on what's
arguably the single most important
incubator of elite opinion in the world
both sides make their case you decide
that's free speech that's democracy
liberal people
used to be in favor of it
well my first guest tonight is a
passionate advocate for free speech and
she also knows more than most about what
it's like to be trolled online a lot of
them say that Caitlyn Jenner joins me
now I think from Hollywood Caitlyn how
are you
you know what Pierce I'm doing just fine
actually very excited to see what's
going to happen to social media now that
uh Elon Musk is in control of Twitter I
think it's going to be very interesting
in the future actually if I could and
this is going to take a little while for
social media to kind of get used to this
the Elon Musk here it's kind of almost
like when Liv golf came in uh to the
gulf world the PGA kind of had a
monopoly going here well social media
has had a monopoly on
um you know the far left and and finally
Elon Musk came in and he wants a free
speech platform for everybody the left
the right and I think it's going to be
good and I think it's going to really
shake up social media you look at Mark
Zuckerberg it was reported last week he
lost like a hundred million dollars or
100 billion dollars whatever it was and
value of meta because he's been so far
left for so long and a voice for the
left
that people are leaving and going
someplace else so this is going to take
some time to figure out exactly how it's
going to work out but I think it's going
to be very good in the long run for
social media yeah I mean I completely
agree and I think Elon Musk you know
he's proven himself to be a a genius who
likes to challenge Orthodoxy in terms of
how we think whether it's electric cars
whether it's SpaceX is extraordinary uh
space company which does all these
Starling satellites as well you know and
now this I think he's the right guy
because as I keep trying to explain to
people he's not even someone who
identifies as right-wing or conservative
you know he's a Bernie Sanders fan he
spent most of his life actually
positioning himself politically to the
left and yet it's the people on the left
who have gone so far left in my opinion
that it makes people who are on the
center or maybe even slightly center
right look like they're far right by
comparison that's that's been the
problem
no Elon Musk I think is going to be very
good for Twitter I I have met him on a
couple of occasions
um actually I got a I'm into Aviation
and I got a private tour of SpaceX where
they uh down at Hawthorne where they
build the rockets and he gave me an hour
tour we sat in his office he was
wonderful
um and I think he's he is a big thinker
I mean when you say you're going to
start space like a space company and
you're going up uh you know against NASA
that takes a lot you know it takes some
pretty big ones there and uh I think
he's going to do the same thing here the
first thing he's starting up with is
he's going to make it as a subscription
um
where he has Twitter blue uh I think one
of the reasons why when he first got in
and started looking into Twitter uh he
saw that there were so many accounts
that you couldn't verify and he wants to
be able to verify it so he's going to
put up for 19.95 you can get a verified
account on Twitter blue and I think
that's going to be very good you're
you're going to get rid of a lot of the
junk that's out there
um he's immediately started firing all
the top Executives in fact I think it
was today he completely fired the entire
Board of Twitter uh bringing his people
in actually he's bringing in a lot of
technical people from uh from Tesla and
he's going to shake this thing up I
think it's going to be
so interesting to watch and I think it's
going to be nothing but good you know
I've been on Twitter I've been Shadow
banned in fact interesting uh I was
Shadow banned the day it was announced
that I joined Fox News as a contributor
I immediately got it but it's funny it's
funny you say that you say that Caitlyn
because oddly I'd noticed over the last
few months my twits are following uh
number had gone down quite slowly but
steadily for months and months and
months I was losing followers but in the
last two weeks since it looked like Elon
Musk was basically going to be taking it
over I've suddenly gained all the
followers I lost in two weeks now it
might be coincidence
it might be I don't know they were
taking away Bots or something like that
or it might just be that from the moment
it looked like Elon Musk was actually
going to run Twitter a lot of the people
doing this kind of Shadow Banning which
for people who don't know they put you
know stuff in the technology which
basically reducing the visibility of
people they perceive to be conservative
or maybe anti-woke or whatever it may be
certainly in my case it would be
anti-woke not conservative but I I smell
a rat here and I think you probably have
experienced similar stuff right
I've experienced the same thing you know
here's a little trivia
uh I broke a Guinness Book of World
Records on Twitter
when I came out and the guy was not on
Twitter when I came out uh was on the
cover of Vanity Fair
uh I immediately when that came out I
immediately opened up my Twitter account
and I broke the world record for a
broken set of Guinness Book of World
Records for the fastest to 1 million
followers
um Barack Obama had it at five hour five
hours and and like 20 minutes uh I did
it in four hours and two minutes from
zero to one million I would expect black
inside I don't expect nothing else from
a Olympian gold medal champion
yes and so
um yeah I've been with Twitter for a
very long time and yes I've been Shadow
banned I have also noticed in the last
couple of weeks things have started to
change uh your amount of engagements is
going up
um I think it's honestly I think this is
going to be good not just for Twitter
but
social media okay if you were Elon and
you're looking at all the problems of
Twitter and I think we all know what
they are there are way too many
Anonymous Bots and they can influence I
think political uh issues in a
manipulative way which could potentially
then manipulate votes and therefore
elections I think that remains a big
concern also this the amount of abuse
you know racism harassment death threats
and so on is still there I see it you
know every now and again where it's ugly
head yeah
um where for you where is the life and
it's a very interesting debate this
about where the line is for free speech
where is free speech and where for you
who's been on the subject of a lot of
abuse and trolling where for you is the
line that gets crossed
well first of all I think that's in Elon
musk's hands right now and the people
that he brings in he has to bring in
some really good competent people to be
able to run Twitter because obviously
hate speech shouldn't be anywhere
um it shouldn't be online it shouldn't
be anywhere and there is that fine line
between hate speech and something that's
either true or maybe not quite as you
know true it's almost like for me it's
almost like I get a lot of jokes about
me I've been roasted in this and
everything and there is that fine line
between a funny joke that is really true
okay and a funny joke that is like
hateful to me that always I don't want
hateful jokes against me I want funny
jokes against me and you can use me and
I love as good a laugh as anybody but
it's going to be the same thing with
Twitter
um where is that fine line and I think
he's going to have to have very
competent people in there to be able to
find out where that fine line is well
it's interesting you mentioned comedy
because he he actually tweets it comedy
is legal again oh yeah and I I responded
by tweeting back two laughing emojis and
a thumbs up which he then he then liked
very quickly so I and being liked by
Elon Musk on Twitter at the moment is a
bit like getting a Papal Blessing from
the pope if you're a Catholic
um you know it's not the ultimate
validation um and it shows of course his
only incredible engagement in Twitter I
mean he's all over it he reads
everything he sees everything he's
firing out tweets
I don't know how he does it the guy's
got a million things going on in his
life you know he's sending Rockets up to
space he's uh you know developing the
electric car which nobody said they
could really do and do it right and he
didn't still Tesla's the best electric
car on the market SpaceX uh is just
killing the only way uh any you know
astronauts can get to the space station
is now SpaceX NASA doesn't have any way
to get him there right so he's done an
amazing job but I think he'll do the
same thing with with Twitter it's going
to take a little time to work it out but
I think Elon Musk is really good at
getting
good people in the right place I agree
and if they're not working out he's
afraid he's not he's not you know afraid
to fire himself what would you do write
people in place but he said today if he
had a I think he had a dime or a dollar
for everyone he's uh asked him what he's
going to do about Donald Trump he'd be
very rich which of course he's already
very rich he's got 235 billion dollars
but what would you do about Donald Trump
would you let him back on the platform
oh of course yeah why it's a free speech
platform now of course I would of course
I would you know what it's interesting
how the left is already starting to come
after him just uh on uh what was it just
today uh of course a is Senator Chris
Murphy a Democrat from Connecticut okay
on this Monday uh said that they have to
review Twitter because
um
um for the committee of foreign
investment why because the Saudis a lot
of people don't know this the Saudis
have big been been big investors in
Twitter for many many years I think they
hold about
1.89 uh billion dollars in investment in
Twitter most people don't know that but
now all of a sudden the left's gonna
come after and say hey we have to check
out these Investments
Saudi Arabia's been around for a long
time with Twitter they're the number two
uh stockholder behind uh Elon Musk but
the left's going to take their shots
um I think Elon musk's a very sharp guy
I mean my argument about it I'll give it
about Trump has been from the start of
this is if you're going to ban Donald
Trump you can't then allow as they've
allowed Vladimir Putin to retain his
Twitter account Taliban leaders the
supreme leader of Iran there's no
consistency there right you know you
cannot allow people like that to have
accounts and say Donald Trump should be
banned in my in my opinion it's not a
question of being right or left or any
of these things it's a question of
balance and consistency and I do think
the one thing Elon Musk is going to do
he's going to bring in a kind of a a
group of people from all walks of life
all political Persuasions and they're
going to be the ones who form a
consensus about who should be bad
because there are some people who I
think probably should be bad you know if
you're going to be a spewing you know
racism or stuff which endangers people's
lives I would say Alex Jones for example
would be one example to me where by
spewing his lies about Sandy Hook and
imperiling the lives of the relatives of
the the poor kids who died I don't think
you should have a platform to do that
and endanger their lives personally um
so I think there is a line and I think
he's going to get there with a group of
people which will be far more rounded
politically probably than the than the
current leadership group at Twitter
no I totally agree with you I think
again Elon Musk is very good at picking
the right people to go to the right
places
um yeah hates peace on Twitter should
not be there
um maybe a different point of view that
can be there you know for the first time
because
the problem with Twitter is that
they have
been just you know for the left
and they ban people who's on the right
like my case Shadow band I work I'm a
conservative I love this country they
will do everything to
uh limit my speech okay but that doesn't
happen on the left I mean they just
totally let it go I think what now with
Elon Musk taking over it's going to be a
lot much more
um well balanced as far as um uh who's
on Twitter and what's what I'm going to
ask you I know you don't want to talk
about this in any depth I completely
understand why because you have
obviously a personal connection here but
uh Kanye you know yay West who I
interviewed last week actually in the
U.S you know there's a a big debate
about whether he should be given social
media platforms now so setting aside
your the fact you obviously know him uh
through the family what's your view
what's your view about what he said and
whether he should have a platform
first of all any anti-semitic remarks
should be totally condemned by everybody
no matter if it's on Twitter or wherever
it is so that's where I stand as far as
um and that type of speech shouldn't be
around
yeah that to me that is a line that if
that gets crossed that that should be it
um Caitlin it's great to talk to you I
love you coming on the show please come
back soon you always talk a lot of sense
and I really appreciate it it it's
always good to talk to you pierce thank
you
well next tonight chaos in the channel
chaos and a migrant processing center in
chaos over her use of private emails and
government business is
about to be fired again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to please welcome since I'm
pretty sure I'm secretary swella
bravaman is facing fresh demands as she
quits tonight just days after rishi's
sunlight reappointed her and what a
Christian looks like his first major
misstep as prime minister she's admitted
sending sensitive government documents
to her personal email accounts six times
in as many weeks now she's under
pressure of the chaos of the migrant
processing center where 4 000 people are
packed into the facility built for just
1600. this evening she told the House of
Commons at the Asylum system she runs is
broken and that Britain is facing an
invasion
let's take a look
the British people deserve to know which
party is serious about stopping the
invasion
and the coast and which party is not
some 40
000 people have arrived on the south
coast this year alone many of them
facilitated by criminal gangs some of
them actual members of criminal gangs
thank you very much indeed for joining
tonight
good evening Pez here's my question
about leaky Sue is she's been
unfortunately nicknamed because of all
the things that she's leaked which is
when Rishi sunak became prime minister
and reappointed her for six days after
she's been effectively fired from
government
um I said at the time I thought that was
a big mistake that I thought you cannot
bring somebody back that fast and I also
suspected as we're now seeing there
would be more to come in terms of the
stuff that was being held against her
um you can't be happy surely as a
conservative peer to see all this
attention now back on swella bravaman
and indeed all this detail from this
Migrant Center where it looks like she
has been at least partly responsible for
a lot of chaos there
well I don't think she's responsible
she's only been in the job for 12 weeks
you know this is a massive problem peers
as you know which has been building for
a considerable time 28 000 38 000
migrants have come to this country this
year this is only the start with the
global starvation that's happening
around the world and I've been traveling
around the world recently in
commonwealth countries and seen the real
trouble that's ahead and we will have
more of these uh migrants coming in and
as another point you know there are 117
000 people waiting for Asylum
this is the size of town
sorry my response
can I just sorry let me interrupt how
long have we had sorry can I just go
on you carry on carry on over you my
question for you then I know where you
were going with that my question for you
is I thought the conservatives had been
in charge for many years of this country
why is the Asylum system so broken why
are these centers so dangerously
overcrowded why is nothing working why
are we processing just four percent of
people what is going on and by the way
who else can you possibly blame but the
conservatives
well I'm not uh going to shoulder that
blame but the the issue is there is a
government there is the wheels of
government that is meant to be dealing
with this appalling crisis and our
sorrow goes out to those people who are
having this terrible suffering having to
lean their own countries but this is a
crisis been going on for a long time
they can't get a chief executive for the
Border Force they're only paid 150 000
they've had to promote from within the
the lack of quality of people is
obviously and management is is not
helping this cause you and I go to we
travel a lot we return to this country
it takes us half an hour 45 minutes to
get through
um through the Border force and they
then look as if it was something the
cats brought in I'm not surprised in my
case but in yours you've probably got a
red carpet but you know the system of
government has broken down and that is a
real issue for any Minister coming in
and I I think with uh home office
officials apparently only working 50 of
the time in the office there has got to
be a real sea change in the attitude of
the Civil Service to dealing with this
crisis because they are there in
perpetuity
well look again I hate to be churlish
here but you're painting a very Grim
picture of this whole system as indeed
Suella bravaman did earlier in the
Commons but again I need to remind you
as you're a conservative peer and as I
would remind her if I had her on the
show but she won't come on it's actually
been a conservative government that's
presided over this catastrophe over the
last decade you can't pass the buck it's
the bucks with you guys
the
there's no I'm not standing here passing
the buck at all I'm merely saying that
the the levers of government have let
the country down in lots of different
ways over the last two to three years
and this is one of them and it's coming
to a real crisis it's coming to a crisis
because there is seemingly no cessation
to it it's going to increase and I'd
like to know what the Border Force are
doing about it and and what steps
they're going to be taking and of course
it requires a leader in the home office
to deal with it but they can only
operate as a leader with the right tools
that's my point and I think you you
understand that point okay well I mean I
think Zoella bravaman is being blamed
for all this and maybe she will be
blamed for it all but she shouldn't be
blamed for this because she's anything
there for a short period of time well it
looks like a lot of people are blaming
you including people right at the heart
of government and I come back to my
central point if you've been fired for
breaching ministerial rules you
shouldn't be getting the same job back
six days later yeah you know as I think
it was Chris Bryant said in the comments
today you know I'm all for Second
Chances and Redemption we've got to
serve some sentence first is the way I
normally understood Justice let's bring
in um Jonathan Ashworth who's the
shallow work and pension secretary uh
Mrs you're smirking away there is is
that because you find the conservative
position on this of of the brass neck
variety
I mean it's staggering isn't it I mean
they've been in power for 12 years peers
and how many home secretaries have we
had they've all been Tory home
secretaries in those 12 years and I'm
afraid so other brother meant is a total
liability and she's only in place
because of this grubby deal between her
and Rishi sunak which and in the end it
was a Monumental failure of judgment on
sunak's part to bring her back and all
this oh it's not her fault well you know
there's these question marks tonight as
to whether she was clear about whether
she commissioned these extra hotel rooms
or not the source is coming out saying
she wasn't entirely what she said in the
House of Commons isn't entirely correct
this is an absolute shambles and it's a
shambles taking place on the concern
should she should she resign again I
mean I cut look her career is clearly
going down the toilet whether she'll
survive or not I do not know it's we
read understand tonight that the kind of
right-wing Boris Johnson Style ERG Tory
MPS
uh sort of trying to support her and
that number 10 the Rishi sunak people
are hanging around to dry what are
shambles last week Rishi sunak told us
he was going to bring back integrity and
professionalism I just think it shows
you that when it does come to Rishi
sunak he does have he is weak and this
is a failure of his judgment well I mean
Lord Marlin you know I'm actually a bit
of a fan of Rishi sunac certainly by
comparison to his two predecessors
um but I do think this is a big mistake
I do think you can see the volume of
attention now on Sue Ella bravaman is
getting so intense he might get forced
into relieving of her duties again and
that will be a big blow to his
Premiership very early on
well you and I have observed politics
for a very long time peers and of course
none of that would surprise us uh you
know this immigration issue has been
going on for a very long time it's been
a big problem for the country we're a
small island uh Tony Blair was the first
who really let the floodgates open so to
hear the camp from labor is a little bit
Rich we've now inheriting a very
significant problem it needs serious
grasp and uh real meaningful attempt to
sort this matter out for the good of the
country there's no point point scoring
over this it needs the home office to
get a grip it needs as you as you have
identified real leadership to get hold
of it and let's hope we do because
otherwise it's just going to get
catastrophically worse we're going to
have loads and loads of people appearing
here we can't cope with them we haven't
been able to cope with them and it's
going to be a mess a real mess Jonathan
Ashworth my issue with the labor party
position is on all for Point scoring by
the way I think that's what makes the
political world go around but I'm not
entirely sure that you lot have a clue
what to do about this problem either
I've not really seen any great idea from
a labor party which will solve this
problem well I mean first of all Tony
Blair stopped being prime minister I
think 15 years ago so it's pretty it's
pretty weak when the Tories are saying
oh it's all Tony Blair's fault I mean
goodness sake get a grip man you've been
in power for 12 years or your party's
been in power look what would labor do
well first of all we know that criminal
gangs are exploiting this system because
it takes so long to process we used to
be processing around 28 000 a year we're
now processing 14 000. there's some
people waiting like you know the average
weight is like 400 weeks it's well over
a year to process some of these claims
if you're processing quicker and had a
firm Fair system we're getting you know
obviously refugees and Asylum Seekers
who are with genuine claims they
obviously we should be Humane and
compassionate but the people who are
being those who are exploiting the
system those they need those they they
need the applications processed and if
they're not got the right to stay here
then we need what would you do with the
the fact that the majority now of the
people coming over on these boats appear
to be Albanian men so they're not from a
war-torn country seeking genuine Asylum
or Refugee status they appear to be
economic migrants well their
applications need to be turned around
quickly and you know where people are
Asylum Seekers and refugees we are a
compassionate country and we're proud of
our compassionate nature but where
people are are exploiting the system of
course we should be doing all we can to
return them to other countries which is
also why you need a deal you need a deal
with France as well in this and we've
not got a deal but part of this problem
is if you're not processing quickly if
you're leaving people languishing for
400 Days then criminal gangs will
exploit this system and that in the end
does come back to the Tory home
secretaries because that's what we've
been hearing from uh our friend in the
House of Lords there he's he he himself
is conceding that it's been a shambles
that there's all kinds of problems well
I think the one thing one thing we can
all agree on is it's been a complete
shambles and it's getting worse not
better and that's a very bad reflection
on the succession that people put in
charge of this country and we can only
hope that if zuela bravoman does survive
and I've got to say I think the jury is
out on that that she does something
about this which works because the
Rwanda policy which we were told was her
dream has already turned out to be a
complete Fiasco I've got to leave it
there little Marlon thank you very much
as always you I'm going to say to your
great credit you come and face the music
on behalf of the conservative party when
many Run for Cover or hide in fridges
and I appreciate it and uh and Jonathan
Ashworth you always I live on the
privilege of being on your show peers
only some of your colleagues have a
similar attitude the world would be a
finer place but thank you to you both
appreciate it no thanks a lot well still
to come I'm going to talk to the Royal
expert who bleeds King Charles will
strip Prince Harry and his wife Meghan
Markle of their titles if his new book
trashes The Queen console Camilla and
next I'm joined by Mike after they've
made the problem and debacle The Guitar
World Cup and
Nadine Doris I think we've had another
certainly you won't want to miss this
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
well welcome back as Elon Musk the new
boss of Twitter himself said I hope even
my worst critics remain on Twitter
because that's what Free Speech means
exactly right and indeed to celebrate
this statement one of my worst critics
is joining me now tonight welcome to you
Matthew said from the Sunday Times good
to have you thank you Kevin McGuire my
old friend of course in the Daily Mirror
uh and Emily Sheffield the
long-suffering co-presenter of Piers
Morgan uncensored with Nadine Doris that
went well
I'll tell you what let's have a quick
look at Nadine Doris in action because
it was sort of monumentally
spectacularly fascinating
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored
coming up on tonight's program for a
change and money was going to clear up a
woman's mess but rishi's bar was the
entrance number 10.
as as you were student activity extends
to the cabinet with the big beef steak
and all our cages that fragments back at
Hope in the home office sorry I was
completely
they're in our studio and we've risked
them for a clue stick around for just
stop oil live
you know I told them to get somebody on
it wasn't quite as good as me but that
was ridiculous
um no it's not not as easy as it looks
is it Nadine I should stick to politics
actually maybe not anyway um
do you've got a great book out about
Free Speech genuinely mean that it's a
good book of reasons but I can't let
this opportunity go without reminding
you what you once said about a public
figure in this country he takes crude
stances he seeks scapegoats for complex
problems he goads guests into simplistic
answers and humiliates them when they
think best we've returned to the studio
a parasite on the Contours of democracy
a temporary hero to the deluded souls
for whom he becomes a cheerleader he
doesn't simply care about what soapbox
he's on provided it's topical and
divisive now for the benefit of the
viewers
beloved public figure was that that was
if memory says I think that was you it
was me it was me uh and you know what we
live in a democracy I believe in free
speech like you do we have locked horns
many times but actually I thought given
what's going on with Elon Musk and given
the fact you've written a book about
Free Speech the best way for me to show
that I mean it is to have one of my more
voracious Critics on and to say you know
what we can disagree with each other and
hopefully at the end of it we might like
each other a little bit more than we
started we shouldn't be difficult and
and In fairness I think I should point
out that in response a barbed response
to that column uh on television the next
morning you played out a clip before we
come with a journalist I think you know
as a table tennis player of the British
number one for 10 years and he played a
clip of me losing badly to the German
play and he said this guy's a choker if
he can't win at table tennis how can we
take his opinion seriously on anything
else I think it's funny you gave as good
as you I played down to every worst fear
you had about my behavior it'll be good
to see you
um right let's let's talk about Elon
Musk for a moment then Matthew because I
think it's a really interesting thing
that's happening here because musk is
not a right winger but only conventional
stat he's a Bernie Sanders fan one of
them the left-wing politicians in
America he's always historically talked
about being on the left and yet it's the
left that are going most nuts about him
taking over Twitter I think because
they're used to really having their own
way on Twitter where it's the right they
get Shadow banned it's the right to get
banned completely Trump and so on and
it's never the ones on the left who
often in my view babe just as describe
gracefully well for me the great
strength of of liberal Democratic
societies is that we have opinions we
express them hopefully courageously and
occasionally in a slightly ad hominem
fashion but in order to dispute
someone's view you should refute it you
should come up with evidence as to why
it's wrong when we censor other opinions
we denied the opportunity to engage with
them we can often push them underground
they can develop a greater cachet I
don't have a problem with listening to
people who disagree with me and it was I
think voltaire's most eminent biographer
I will defend to the death you're right
to say even that with which I disagree
we lose that in Liberal societies if we
have a liberal set of Institutions
cohabiting with an illiberal mindset I
think it weakens us and it strengthens
you know what the truth we have a lot
more in common than you think because I
completely agree Emily this is the
number of it for me is that the very
people who call themselves Liberals are
behaving in not just an illiberal way
but actually with this canceled culture
mentality almost like the fascist that
they profess to hate most
well I think one of the more worrying
things I've seen is is people at sort of
Oxford and Cambridge University where
you're not allowed to go and talk that
sort of de-platforms and only if you're
on the right only if you're a
conservative but even some of these were
like really miles it was it was like
there certainly weren't my opinion of
what was on the right and
um I don't think many peoples of what
was on the right and you know we've just
seen this with the Trans debate there
are lots of nuances to many arguments
right if you don't sit and debate a
nuance and complex issues how how are
you going to come up with Solutions or
you can't just yeah
right for 40 years like the sun the
telegraph the male and the express
trying to get people banned and lose
their jobs for saying things they find
unacceptable right yes there's
intolerance on the left there's a huge
number of I was about to say I was about
to tee you up by saying I think there
are a lot of people on what I call the
radical end of both end of the spectrum
right and left who unfortunately
dominate a lot of the noise and airspace
you know there's an amazing stat that 20
of people in Britain and America are on
Twitter but of that 20 10 of those make
eighty percent of the noise and they
tend to skew radical so you're getting a
sort of constant reverberation of
extremity of opinion and that is I think
diluting democracy in the process well
there's much to be angry about but of
course if you're on Twitter or more
social media platforms the more outrage
you make the more followers you will get
and we saw bravaman tonight the Home
Secretary because she's accused of uh of
unlawful Behavior because she's accused
of ignoring the ministerial code and she
gets she said gets a job back after six
days she talks about an invasion of the
south coast and she knows that is
incredibly inflammatory 24 hours after a
petrol bomb attack on October but she
does that because half of Twitter and
the country will say yeah you're quite
right we've been Invader and the other
half will say that's incredibly
important is outrageous could I just ask
you one thing because we were just
looking at this in the Green Room sorry
we were just looking so
um Donald Trump's son has just posted a
picture of a pair of pants and a hammer
well he retweeted somebody else yes as a
Halloween thing about I'm just Nancy
pelosiers interested we've just had
Nancy Pelosi's husband attacked how do
we how do we think about things well
there's a very interesting debate to be
had that's not about anything well I'll
tell you what my answer to that is
however stomach churning that joke may
be
around Halloween there's now this
incredibly puritanical censorship going
on where Halloween happened I know I
know and I find it outrageous and
horrible here's my point though actually
I just come back from La two days ago in
La now almost nobody can wear any
costume on Halloween anymore you're not
even allowed to dress up as Beauty
because somebody somewhere finds it
offensive whereas the whole point of
Halloween is to be grotesquely offensive
you dress up as the worst people in the
world or you mock the worst things that
happen could this be argued and I assume
it can't be otherwise Twitter would have
removed it by now well maybe not is this
inciting hatred this wasn't exactly what
do you think I think there's an
important distinction between who is
cracking down on the expression of an
opinion I think it's very dangerous when
the state gets involved which has the
power right to imprison my Twitter is a
private company it is a private
institution it's part of private
property I think in I would like to see
people argue against other people post I
don't want to get the government
involved I think that's my
points to racial hatred but inside
violence is one of them what do we want
unaccountable billionaires to oh what is
effectively the problems
you have it on Facebook an unaccountable
billionaire owns the Washington Post
Jeff Bezos out of Amazon and that's a
problem but all the journalists they
will tell you he never interferes he's
put loads of money into journalism he's
been a false world we know that because
you're rich and successful doesn't make
you a bad person again I know you're
thinking but we know that Elon Musk is
going to interfere in Twitter because
he's made that point in fact over the
weekend after that hammer attack he
actually retweeted
subsequently but he spread it he's
spreading off the thing
is the devil here's the thing about Elon
Musk he brings in electric cars like
nobody else in history right big tick in
the in the box with me SpaceX
particularly what he's doing with the
Starling satellites which have been
directly helping at vast expense to his
company helping Ukrainian military to
connect with each other when all their
internet and cell phone stuff goes down
right he does a lot of very good stuff
Elon Musk and he's actually identifies
this to the left he just finds the kind
of ultra awoke cancer mentality
completely irrational and destroying
democracy I agree with it we're talking
about free speech and him owning a huge
platform you could have mentioned when
those kids were tapped uh trapped in a
cave in Thailand he he's called one of
the people they're saving one of the
diamonds it did slur so he's out of
control when it comes to free speech
well and he goes over into what you
would call I don't think he hates hang
on hang on okay but it's very
interesting isn't it because insulting
people or being offensive actually if
you believe genuinely in free speech
then you are allowed to do that I can
offend you right now you might be
offended and insulted but doesn't give
you the right to stop me unless I break
a law now if I break a law you have the
right of the criminal justice Act of
this country to come
the question then is what the law should
be I'm with you I think unless it's
physical harm that you are in danger
if it's just an insult so you accept it
though the incitement to violence
Donald Trump off which I don't think it
should be quite hard to prove him I
think Elon Musk didn't agree with that
am I right he didn't think Donald Trump
would have been taken off and and I do
think to Jack dorsey's uh defense I
think they genuinely thought Donald was
using Twitter to incite well I think
it's a very there's a very good argument
that that is the case but if you use
that as the yardstick for Banning Trump
you've got to look at what's happened
with the supreme leader of Iran inciting
hatred against Jewish people you know
with the Taliban selling hatred against
just about everybody
she's currently waging your legal War
Twitter made a lot of money from Trump
by keeping him on for a long time and I
knew he was very strong as a president
it was only when they saw he was going
to be a loser and he was an insight and
Insurrection they took it they took it
unfortunately run out of time because I
loved just just debate I actually think
it's the key debate of our time free
speech I really think it's under attack
like it's ever been and people like Elon
Musk I think are going to be the
champions of saving Free Speech we will
see and we'll debate it again but thank
you you've got very interesting views on
that good to see you Matthew thank you
well coming next well the wine-a-thon
Memoir from Prince Harry be the final
straw of his father King Charles I took
the wallet says this book can see Harry
finally stripped of his remaining titles
and somebody
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back first drafts of Prince
Harry's forthcoming Memoir reportedly
rejected by Publishers sparking concerns
he's ramped up Revelations now likely to
rock the royal family the new book is
called spare an unsubtle wine about his
life in Prince William's Shadow and it's
due out just months before King
Charles's coronation I'm sure his father
is thrilled about what joining me now is
Vanity Fair rules to Katie Nichol and is
still in Dr Tessa Dunlop fresh from her
extraordinary uh performance on Good
Morning Britain to those I've happened
to catch actually you're very fired up
with old Tom Bauer I was extremely angry
on a couple of counts yes yes your
position is that anyone is written about
the Royals has no right to have adverse
comment about Harry doing his Memoir no
that's absolute twisting what I'm about
because I've just written a book out
next week which uh I'm very good at
getting in there yeah Elizabeth and
Philip yeah and I therefore cannot throw
stones at glass houses but I do take
sincere objection to someone like Tom
Bauer see sitting there across the table
from me and having a go at Harry and
Megan raking in the money off the back
of the royal family tell me that Tom
Bauer with his ridiculous book isn't
anything okay here's what I'll say to
that a is a very good journalist and he
never gets sued and Megan is a brilliant
PR person well she might be actually I
don't mind her podcast I don't disagree
disagree that she melts that PR as a
like very few people I've seen but I
think on the potential point he made by
way of Defense which I agree with him
about he's look in the end he's not
Prince Harry he's not given Royal titles
he's not had all the privilege and
wealth become something a royal which is
paid for by the British public it's a
completely different kettle of fish both
of you are royal authors but it's very
very different and I would say Katie
about this this book by Harry if you're
King Charles you're mourning your mother
and your father
no I'm sorry good morning I do believe
that he was sincerely missing his
parents okay if you don't mind I'll
finish my question is mourning both his
parents he's lost in the last two years
he's taken on being king after the
longest apprenticeship in history and
obviously very protective of his wife
Camilla and the word is that Harry is
going to take down Camilla in this book
if that happens why frankly after
they've already been spray gun in the
Royals now for two years and say left
for freedom and privacy why should they
keep the titles of Duke and Duchess of
Sussex a County by the way I come from
where I have spent more time in the last
month than they've spent in their lives
well I I think and I've said this before
I know Tom said it as well but I said it
a while ago I had it on very good
authority from a source close to the
king that if they do trash Camilla
particularly is very very protective as
you would expect of the queen consort
and if they use this as an opportunity
to tarnish not just the repulation of
the crown but to attack Camilla that
really will I think it'll be the nail
and the question for the relationships
they had a popular name on Oprah right
call them a bunch of callous races are
they going to really do it all over
again in a book do you know is if you
don't want this book to succeed if it
asks you that much talking about it
it will succeed it will be a massive
number one bestseller that's not my
argument he's gonna make his money back
by getting out there my point is he is
trashing the very institution yes and
the people at the head of it which have
afforded them the titles which is the
only reason anybody goes it is an
extraordinary gilded cage which comes
with a dump load of privilege and lots
of problems it's a goldfish bowl from
day one princess Elizabeth grew up in
that goldfish Bowl Harry grew up in that
goldfish bowl and couldn't really find
another goal to go with him who wanted
to join him in the Goldfish Bowl which
is why Megan became his savior in many
respects
the queen died one of the most beloved
people in the world indeed she did
because she never complained she never
explained she never whines she never
trashed the monarchy never trashed her
family you had her ups and downs these
two in California want their Royal cake
and eat it they want to make millions
trading off their Royal status while
saying the royal family had God awful by
the way my father's also the queen
Camilla is awful the monarchy is
disgusting and they want to make
millions doing it and I believe
I believe I I wish they weren't but they
are and I believe the British Monarchy
should be broad-shouldered enough to
just let it wash over okay
I think there's there is an
inevitability that if that is what
they're setting out to do it he may not
necessarily by the way none of us have
seen these extras don't actually know
what's in them they're not paying 20
million for nothing
if that is the intention then it can be
okay listen you're both very good Royal
authors you look very fetching in your
King's house
don't like people who are bullied
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]